- All right, let's finish up
with something inspiring
from social media,
this is What I'm Liking.
(audience cheering)
In college, Lauren was a
passionate softball player.
Then she suffered a severe injury
on the field that was devastating
physically and psychologically.
As a way to cope, she turned
to her second love, art,
and it changed horse of her entire life.
Now, not only is she a licensed artist
for Major League Baseball
depicting top athletes
including Clayton Kershaw and Mike Piazza.
She's also using her craft
to celebrate and honor her heroes.
We have Lauren, dialed in right now
who watches on City TV
in British Columbia.
So Lauren, hello?
(audience cheering)
- Hello.
- My, Gosh! You are also very beautiful.
So I'm gonna lead with that.
So how, how did you get into art?
- You know, I started in high school
just kind of as a way to cope with.
I struggled with a bit of mental health
in high school as well.
So it was kind of my
way to cope with anxiety
and depression and things
I didn't really know
how to talk about,
so I did just a little bit then and yeah.
But it was mostly focused on sports.
- Yeah, no, I did the same thing.
That's why I became a songwriter.
I think a lot of people
have to find those outlets
especially around that time in our lives.
It's a hard time.
So you try to give the celebrities
their painting once you've
completed them, right?
- Correct, not always easy, but yes.
(kelly laughs)
- Wait, is it really hard to find them
to give them something beautiful?
- I don't have everyone's
cell phone number,
I make it a surprise.
But yeah, I've delivered
to like Steph Curry,
Russell Wilson, Gordon Ramsey.
- Wow.
- Elle King.
But again, that takes a bit of networking
and yeah, it's not always super easy
but I now have a chance to
present art to you as well.
- Oh, that's awesome.
By the way, I love Elle King.
I love that you did, Elle King.
She's so cool.
Wait, you did this for me.
(audience applauding)
- I did it.
- This is gonna be hung my house tonight.
(audience applauding)
This is so beautiful.
(audience cheering)
- Thank you.
- Wait, so I love that
you have Fort Worth.
You have all these little
things about me too.
And like, I love Aretha, I love this.
- Thank you.
Yeah, I do a bit of research
before I start the project.
I call them gratitude projects.
So I usually look for
someone that's done something
with their platform to make
the world a better place.
'Cause that was the best way
to get out of kind of my
darkness after the injury.
And I had heard in interviews
that Aretha Franklin had inspired you,
and I learned about a
bit where you were from,
so I wanted to tie that into the piece
that I created for you.
- I love it so much.
(audience applauding)
I don't even know if you knew this,
but this ring is actually a
replica of a Jane Austin ring
that I own 'cause I'm
obsessed with Jane Austin.
So it's cool that you even
tied in my love of literature
and you didn't even
probably know you did that,
but it was amazing touch.
I love all of it.
Thank you so much.
This is so beautiful.
(audience applauding)
You're so gifted.
Well thank you so much, Lauren.
I'm liking your post right now, okay?
(ding)
- [Lauren] Perfect.
All right, and that's all
on our season long partner,
Pilot pen makers of G2,
the go-to pen at the Kelly Clarkson show
wanna honor ultimate
overachiever like you,
'cause this is what?
This is overachieving,
that's what it looks like.
So they're gonna write
you a check for a $1,000.
How's that sound?
(audience applauding)
- Thank you.
- Tank you so much.
This is like the coolest
gift ever, seriously.